à la une ce soir une manifestation
antibacine en Touren vous en parlez il y
a quelques instants sans manifestants se
sont réunis à chavegne pour dire non à
un projet de bassin les bassines ce sont
ces équipements qui puisent l'eau pour
alimenter les champs des agriculteurs la
préfecture d'indrloir qui ne s'est pas
opposé à ce projet privé explique que le
dispositif n'est pas aussi important au
cas Saint- Soline par exemple et qu'il
n'a pas le même impact sur
l'environnement et si l'exploitant
annonce finalement renoncer à cette
construction les militants craignent que
des projets similaire voit le jour dans
le département ils étaient une centaine
réunis dans la campagne tourangel ce
samedi réunis pour dire non à un projet
de bassine sur la commune de chaveigne
rassemblé à champini surveud à quelques
kilomètres les militants écologistes ont
distribué des tractes puis se sont
rendus sur l'exploitation concernée et
si l'exploitant vient d'annoncer son
désir de renoncer à la construction du
bassin les manifestants restent prudents
et cherchent à faire entendre leur voix
au-delà de ce projet parti ulier l'idée
c'est pas de faire peur à quelqu'un mais
de d'alerter sur ce mode d'agriculture
il est important de réfléchir à l'usage
de l'eau ensemble parce qu'en fait c'est
pas à noodin de de comme ça d'accaparer
l'eau on a aussi des craintes sur
d'autres projets de bassine avec
d'autres agriculteurs la préfecture
d'indrloire ne s'est pas opposé à ce
projet déclaré en octobre dernier elle
précise par ailleurs qu'il ne s'agit pas
d'une bassine mais d'une bâche avec
merlon de 2,5 haectares un dispositif
avec un impact sur la nature réduit par
rapport aux constructions telles qu'à
saintsoline de son côté la Confédération
paysane souhaite démontrer qu'il est
possible de se passer de ces bassins
comme le font de nombreuses agriculteur
tous les gens qui pratiquent
l'agriculture de conservation des sols
tous les gens qui pratiquent de de
l'agroforesterie tout ça c'est dans le
dans le sens de
s'adapter au dérèglement climatique et
de de s'adapter à des nouvelles
techniques de culture qui vont être
moins à la fois moins peantes et qui
viont aussi respecter le sol pour le
moment l'exploitant n'a confirmé
coralement son retour en arrière aux
dernières nouvelles aucun acte officiel
de retrait n'avait été
entrepris